but buff up cash up up up
number one finance app in the App Store
this show is brought you with a cache
who's that me it's my other boy shows
broad with the cash app it's the number
one finance and having a fucking
[Laughter]
especially when you your friends o you
money or when you want dem fucking money
how you use the cash asking Benton I
said why is it whenever I say I had some
beauty products that support getting me
for free but I don't worth it no more so
I sold them to my friend money how do
you decide what to charge them for
beauty products I let them pick I'm not
crazy I'm just I mean hey what do you
want these for cuz they're gonna buy
them anyways that's a little service but
you're the one that told me that and I
send a lot of stuff for free so don't
get me twisted Cosmetics expired yes
you're selling moldy ass Wow
alright Chad pick it up get back in that
voice cash app is also the easy way to
try and grow your money in the stock
market with the investing features with
the cash app you can instantly
ambassador in stock for as little as one
dollar bra does bro its bro have a
steroid problem did you know that
services are provided but cash app
investing a subsidiary square and
remember it's a PC well now you do the
cash yet and use the promo code Whitney
not only will you instantly receive $10
but the cash app will donate $10 to
Trevor price are you a fan of the term
yeah I love the gays long as you know
I'm a top amazing organization that
provides protective services to LGBTQ q
plus plus youth across America don't
forget the promo code Whitney when you
down the cash app from the App Store
today
[Music]
do you wear headphones or no it's always
weird right
it doesn't make sense when there's two
people it's you and me well why don't
you wear headphones doesn't have a
conversation I don't feel like I'm
flying a plane if there's more than one
person like if there's more than I'm
sorry if there's more than two they need
headphones so you don't talk over each
other oh that's why it's four yeah I
thought it was just look cute
I'm if you are wearing if you want a
raccoon no I mean I know we can you know
what my problem see where's my look I
don't know I just learned that my
microphones not near me how would I
found that it still works though I know
but you guys are doing it big here you
learn from people's mistakes than here
you are that's why I came in late to the
pot game waited for you guys to work out
the kinks and your crush and then I came
in hot and look at this yeah um you have
to wear them why don't you wear them on
your show yeah all your shows um it was
just like kingless things basically with
diovan is basically like a digital TV
show so we don't need headphones okay
and then me and Kalyn it's just I don't
know we've been doing so long
we interrupt each other that's what we
do we never lay each other finish it is
[Laughter]
how do we you and I know you were never
on dating ABS no never never ever they
weren't cool when there's some cool oh
they're not well no they are they're
cool now no actually Bumble hinge people
love and hinges one now be a part of
anything called a hinge and then I think
Grindr might have take a hit after
someone filleted up man no oh you
talking about I know you talk about that
documentary
don't fuck with cats
I think they met on Grindr um mm yeah
maybe I didn't watch that because I
can't you know me I'm too sensitive for
that shit I didn't know a guy on Grindr
went on a date with a guy in the guy
hung him upside down and filleted him
that's what the news use the word fillet
in Italy and it ruined the grinder I
mean you'd I don't think they took a hit
but it definitely is what comes up first
when you google it what means you don't
worry about saying stuff on your podcast
that's one of my questions for you hmm
because sometimes get the straw that
straw touch and go for a minute
you know what's funny as you say that
it's so do you ever get in trouble for
like clowning on brands has anyone ever
come after you guys
no one's ever and can you bring it up
again since I reopen the case rehab I
was - if you people can clip stuff out
and make up whatever they write remember
I was talking about this show on that I
get some shit for this new show on Fox
on how I was saying are they the best
for the job is that the best panel and
happy three black guys but before I was
talking about how the best commentator
in the game is an african-american
mm-hmm so they skipped all that just cut
out that right was like what just in
like comments and stuff oh yeah you
don't read your Co like I should fear
for about two minutes I used to when I
was younger I did now I don't and did it
did you start reading it more once you
started doing stand-up no no way you
read it before I would read it before I
read during the podcast but then it's
just hot like it's a toxic world but I
also think that like in sports
especially in comedy like people just
talk shit that's the other thing is that
I feel like a lot of people I've been
this bad comic dude people are just
talking shit any time I respond to
someone's negative comment they're like
oh my god I'm so sorry oh hell you
didn't think you were gonna read this I
think it's gotten maybe a little worse
because again with King in this thing
with Theo and I basically just roasting
each other and roasting the Oh whatever
people submit videos we're just roasting
non-stop so then like I'll walk in a
show and like this mom like I'm your
biggest fan
you look like shit
but I'd be cool I actually defend people
that are fans that talk shit because I
think we teach them that that is how
they can talk to us like I did the roast
for so long and I have to take
responsibility for the fact that I did
that people think I'm way tougher than I
am
they think I love getting made fun of
because i sat there on TV and laugh when
people were like witty if she opens her
mouth comes gonna come out or whatever
it I would like laughs they would say if
it's witty it's good but when that's you
know when it's like you can tell you can
tell the difference waiting like finally
all right but they think it's witty it's
not witty - yeah and I'm like come on
man I'm so much I'm gonna be like hey
Khan it was like Jesus but I get why you
think you can talk to me like that yeah
yeah it doesn't used to bother me now no
it doesn't mean how did what I don't
learn real friends I don't think people
know that legit friends you're my best
best legit girlfriend maybe yeah that's
true
I mean brighten up for you you have like
a million friends you don't remember how
we met
I do I just hit me we met through Bryan
Callen mm-hmm I remember I just got to
LA and Bryan was like oh you got to meet
my friend Whitney blah blah blah he's
like she's great she's funny and then I
think me and Bryan were at a dinner or
we're doing some group dinner and then
you came there and then you and I met
and talked there incorrect
oh really I'm off see T's a motherfucker
yeah oh that shit never happened
so no uh Brian asked me to call into the
fighter and the kid oh but that's on
phone I know that was that wasn't phone
but I grossly misjudged because I think
I started making fun about the year who
remained him yes remember that and it
wasn't I just that was it was also at a
time in my life when it was just like
everything was like barb barb barb barb
and I remember after I remember you
getting kind of like silently who the
fuck is this then when we first met you
were like I thought you were like
so mean yeah yeah did it feel like
that's not for something mad that's all
we're like on the fly think I'm right
cuz then you then you get my podcast so
I'm right you came to that dinner was
the dinner it was in Venice yep there
were a lot of like weird Venice dinners
yeah but that was it cuz I remember yeah
you called in for the art podcast yeah
didn't it sound like you're in a
helicopter
I kept making fun probably yeah that's
right and then yeah and then like weeks
later we should find that and listen to
it I don't know where those there's no
way we'd be a you don't have them online
I don't know where they're like me and
Brian on whatever I'm like episode 600
yeah we have like four to five hundred
somewhere else
Wow I don't know where they're at and
then what was your impression of me when
we first talked on the phone are you
saying it don't turn that interview yeah
oh my gosh is that your main I thought
you'd like I mean that's the only way I
knew how to relate to new people is like
making fun of them or like I don't know
and also you were so funny and I was a
go shit like this guy's like not quick
and I think it annoyed me yeah and I
wanted to I want to like dominate I
don't know what it was like I know but I
think that also for so long as a and I
don't play the like female comic card
that I think is a female comic you also
have to like let people know like we're
friends yeah
real fast you know especially people
that are funny it's a way of just going
like this isn't flirting setting the it
it's like making yourself neutering
yourself yeah or something yeah you know
so just be as annoying as possible so
this person would never have any
attraction yes exactly I think that
don't you think though that like I mean
do you ever do that when you're like
meeting women you have to just be like
we're friends and you have to like do
something to kind of just like make that
super clear no I'm nice too I treat
everybody the exact same so I think you
can get me in trouble but I don't I
don't know how to do it any other way
like I've never mean because I'm always
worried someone's kind of preconceived
notions I mean like that's that way it's
me like the way I look like either a
dumb you just mean yeah you know some
boys I go over the top the people think
you're gonna be
mean oh yeah my tattoos my ears I think
I thought that about you a little bit
too I think I was maybe intimidated by
you and I felt the need to kind of like
yeah so I'm Bo yeah so I try to break
that wall right away I also I'm like the
nicest person I feel like you don't
think so I think you're really nice but
I think that when when you want your you
have such an acumen for being able to
call out bullshit and tell the truth
that I would not want I would not want
to hear what you had to say to about me
when I was not around cuz I think you'd
be right
interesting but even especially when we
first met even when you weren't around I
was not nasty about it yeah
I have no reason I knew you and your
apart anyway oh that's so true not using
you for your money don't like you for
that yeah yeah you and your just ball
and we did we didn't date
I think everyone thinks we like day to
day today didn't date date we'd like I
say we hung out hung out we hung out we
hung out like one seven is all what we
would go to Chipotle just to pull it and
you're like I remember getting your
house you had all these drinks like you
know the drinks you get her one we're
like each is like $30 and I was like is
that rose water you like it sure is like
holy shit I remember looking at like
gonna like I found treasure I was like
and every time come on I can have a
drink like you don't have to keep asking
oh you can have someone like restock
them all it sounds like wow and don't
remember I remember I used to I was
trying to be healthy and I thought that
like juice was healthy it's before I
really knew how juice on juice light
that's argue that but I think that it
was it was a weird time because I think
things are confusing when you meet
someone that's probably meant to be a
platonic friend and you're like don't
you just have to get that like hanging
out stuff like out of the way so you can
then become friends yeah I think I think
well also when you and I met I was like
in the thick of fighting to and life was
moving so fast for me and it was like I
met you as being this person I met this
person and I'm like going through you
know so it's like we met at a weird time
we met it Avira member and I just got it
I don't mean it but I was like I was
literally I was like a blind guy trying
to figure out the wall like I just got
to LA yeah Ryan's my budding all this
stimulus and I mean D'Elia and Will
Sasso I'm hang out with them every
weekend and then I'm still fighting out
big fights coming up but it's like I'm
not into it I want to I want to be like
you guys and yeah I'm like torn then I
meet you and you're super nice I mean
and I we say this when I give the
opportunity to I was good the person the
first person ever to believe me do
stand-up with you from the very jump if
you remember it's true because I
remember I was doing a speech at Ohio
State for the national championship game
and I asked you because you did one for
that pen I think oh yeah I spoke at
their graduation
yeah it was like now I need some tips
and then yeah I remember you helped me
on that and oh yeah and you're like I
remember we were driving somewhere like
you know you're me doing this like
whenever you decide or you're me doing
this should be performed front of crowds
as a cap she's crazy too or from
Chipotle that's right and I I just look
I'm I don't want to give anyone any more
credit than they deserve I just remember
you being so quick in your brain being
so quick and you always having such a
funny devil's advocate observation
that's what comedy is often taken
devil's advocate and I remember you
truly making me laugh like nothing makes
comics laugh anymore and I just was like
oh he's gonna be a comic like what is
all this why are you icing your knee
what is all this shit like I just
remember being like what's up what are
you doing you look I'm at home icing my
knee I can't go anywhere and I was like
this is such a waste but it was whatever
the your the very first one that I met
who was like dude you could do this and
then also I think when you said I was
quick and stuff like that I remember I
was so intimidated
intimidated by you because you're so
smart I was tell people how smart you
are so I'm so into it so I thought
well I'm not gonna outsmart her so I got
it I gotta be on it man so I'd always
try to make you always try to make you
laugh always oh that's so funny cuz I
was so intimidated or so smart I did not
that's so it's so funny to deconstruct
things and look back because I did not I
never felt that I always felt I open
mics worst driving to Chipotle that's so
weird
I never I could you seemed so impossible
to intimidate and you always I feel like
we used to laugh so hard about such a
[Laughter]
figure out like I also was a time where
I never knew if I was there was like a
vagueness around hanging out with people
and I never wanted to because people
would always go win you emasculate man
you emasculate man which I don't think
that's true
I don't I don't think that's true I
think you intimidate him yeah but I
don't but not not by your doing I think
you're tending but it's their own
insecurities and I also was a top ten
having UFC and I was intimidated and I'm
saying I was like good that's so crazy
to me I never felt that from you and
never came off I always felt no but I
wasn't like oh I don't want to hang out
with her I was like oh this is dope I
got to bring something to the table huh
I don't feel like fucking Steadman makes
the whole fro I always but I never and I
think because when I first met you I was
like making jokes I was like don't do
that just don't be funny and then I
always was like oh I'm just being too
boring just like overthinking it you
know and no I remember one time we were
I was like no I think we're just friends
I remember going we're friends stop
overthinking it you have lots of guy
friends cuz I've so many guy friends
somebody got to that I'm always just
like oh this is just another what am I
putting everybody thinks you're you
they're your friend me yes
everyone thinks they're Whitney's friend
really I think so I think I have lots of
guy friends and I've been very careful
to not date comics because I don't piss
where you eat it's been some like
Darwinian survival instinct that's just
come in you know yeah but also comics
are fucking crazy so there's that too
but I haven't had a lot of comics hit on
me people think that Callens the only
guy that's ever tried to hook up with me
when I was way younger you're 17
no I was like out of age I wasn't 26
he's the only person than ever like that
tracks freakin that I was like I just
heard laughing and he start laughing it
was alright and now he's the best you
know I kind of wish I had hooked up with
Khaled actually I don't know why I
didn't I think I'd a boyfriend or
something oh it's very funny it just
been so funny to talk about yeah maybe
yeah I mean literally 25 26 then you
just got pulls out as a Marine Priya I
don't think has anyone that's hooked up
with Callen ever come on your show and
talked about it no no no cuz they
haven't hooked up with like anyone we'd
have on the show that's so interesting
oh that's such a good point no but it
was like so he was so funny and charming
about it and I was always just like he's
the best yeah the best I just think I
would have been laughing too hard and
she would have been like oh it's so
creepy I'm glad you did dad here's
another thing my Cal Cal is popping hot
towns very hot he's very handsome and
he's very funny that you don't realize
it but I think Callen is legitimately
hot no Callens unattractive like we joke
about how I make fun of his looks all
time but if you would just acknowledge
and be like dude yeah imagine what
you're gonna look like at 53
motherfucker and then it's like game
over he's also made you like a fuckin
everyone in Hollywood like loves every
female actress like has always had a
crush on Callen like through the 90s the
back of the 20s everyone's always
thought he was hot yeah he's attractive
dude I know it's not I said no no ya
can't listen Kelly gets a lot of shit
I'm so tempted he's good look at he just
you know he's funny as he's ever been
when counting us on stage ever I like go
watch he's the best I know you have to
see him in person so dumb he's so stupid
job he's the best and since he's since
he's I'm sure I can says he won't kiss
since he got separated since divorce me
and Roberto Saturday he's never been
better
his attitude his happiness he's never
been late to a podcast yeah he's enjoyed
and work he's a better dad yeah I'm sure
he's a better co-parent it's just like
you know yeah it's fantastic
he's killing it so we were so I was like
I could never figure
I was like I could never figure out if
we were dating or just friends were
dating or just friends I don't think
either of us knew and whatever is it
crazy I've apologized for all this
before though to me yes I've apologized
to as a kid we met I was crazy yeah yeah
we've definitely talked through it yeah
we've definitely talked through it and
finally shows I was a hot mess I didn't
know what's going on and my thing is I
just don't ever want to initiate
anything because I don't want to come
off to alpha because I've been told you
emasculate men you need to make yourself
smaller don't be intimidated you that I
it's I don't believe it I'm the friends
you're hanging out with at the time I
think at the time guys I think guys tell
me that they're like guys no guy worth
no guy worth your time because five
years ago yeah like comics which is like
you're too intimidating you need to make
yourself smaller so I didn't want to be
the person was like are we dating are we
not dating like I didn't want to be
aggressive so I would kind of just like
wait around and see and I was like we're
not dating and we were like hey we went
to Malibu for the day or something we're
hanging out and we ran into someone I'm
calm that I went to college with and I
was like him and I aren't dating this is
strictly platonic and I went hey I know
that guy from college oh god I Mets we
are hottest the hardest we've ever
laughed by the way we hooked up and he
came on my chest and licked it off at
storage Toby it ruined my day I was like
I just got quiet dry thing is all I can
tell you that too much but too much
though you know with a tear going a lot
but too much didn't talk to me the
entire day wouldn't even ruin the day
too much too comfortable too comfortable
not bros you completely misread the room
not bro straight down the story it
bombing and then you then it's just
driving traffic PCH like this physically
second and there's no music I can figure
out the music to your g-wagen
and you're like flustered I was laughing
about it yesterday I remember when um
fuck
I'm so glad though that you're doing
stand-up and so rich now because I
remember assuming all these cars aren't
I mean assuming you're hitting paying
your bills I don't yes I mean either I
don't know kind of weird I'd make a wish
situation over there I'm gonna be so
funny if you're just like basically like
somehow crowd you posted videos what
exactly this was a Bernie Madoff shit
like I don't know if any this is real
this is might be like you might be in
jail for the rest of your life but uh I
remember coming your house and you were
like drinking back in the day oil out of
a bottle like visual ruff-ruff just roll
out of a bottle guys do as drinking
green juice in the morning and then you
would like eat protein powder and then
just like Alexis wagging fish oil
obviously Jesus brutal Jesus Christ
Rothko I thought comedy was rough as a
rough go this is wild just like ice oil
you're put
in your coffee what the fuck is this
yeah as at that one-bedroom up with
studio in Marina del Rey one but that's
generous yeah no should be sneaking
smell my brothers leave here and I sleep
here and my protein powder takes up the
entire kitchen so if I'm gonna grab the
corner just like get in fetal position
over here on this futon bitch I am rich
like and and then you just no one worked
harder than you I work pretty hard but I
think that you maybe worked harder than
anyone
as far as MMA goes so just in terms of
in life in terms of your podcasts and in
terms of your being a comedian yeah yeah
maybe I don't know yeah everyone would
say you know I don't want that I think
that's a good point
I think everyone all but first pretty
hearts after Bryan Callen I think just
kidding I'm missing like I've just like
the work ethic that you have is just
it's just as impressive to me I'll take
it you know yeah but I yeah especially
in common I feel like I have to do it
cuz I'm so behind the eight-ball cuz I
get started late so I feel like
something yes and no because I think
stage presence is so much of it and you
already had that because you were
performer anyway yeah confidence is such
so much of the beginning of becoming a
comedian is just being comfortable on
stage and being confident and being able
to have presence and patience and being
okay with silence so that's a big part
of it yeah which you can get from
somewhere else
and then I also think that like you know
having something to say is another big
part of being a good comedian Rodney
yeah he started at 60 and if he had
started 20 who knows if he would have
had the same trajectory because by the
time he started he actually had a point
of view yeah that's um commenting is a
good especially the podcast and I do
with Bryan Callen Theo it's like you
know I'm in the gym going back and forth
with these monsters so I think that
helped but I also think you know when
you hear coms go I started at 17 what
point of view did you have any seven
it's well they're just learning stage
presence yeah would you learn somewhere
else yeah and I think
a lot of times when you start too young
you get stuck in your thing yeah then if
you just started at 3035 you would be a
different person and maybe you should
just start that yeah I'm not like I
don't I'm not a purist in that like you
have to have started state it's there's
get to it I used to be self-conscious of
it but that went away you know that went
away I'm not I'm not so self-conscious
now I can I come up to the store the
Laugh Factory yeah my god oh I stopped
thinking about yeah and then what is the
thing that surprised you the most about
doing stand-up you didn't expect I would
say how nice everybody is yeah like I
remember when I first started like I was
you know so my favorite comedians they
were really dark so like you know I get
darker hmm and I remember challenging
being going what are you doing yeah that
guy oh you're the funny loving silly guy
be silly man yeah you think you're not
that guy yeah
and I just remember like everyone's be
so mean to me and think I don't belong
here yeah and it was so nice to me yeah
everyone that's such a solace I had this
thing do you find though that now that
you do stand-up you enjoy watching
stand-up less other people oh that's a
good question because that's a great
question that's kind of my theory about
why commune with people like why are all
comedians miserable because the thing
that gives people the most joy watching
stand-up we lose that we don't get to be
audience members of comedy anymore
because that's our job so the things
that used to bring us joy and escape
movies television comedy stand-up we
don't get to watch that anymore without
being like fuck I should have thought of
that or a fuck that's not such a good
joke or God I have a joke like that I
change me I don't watch it as much and
then I'll so I don't want to see
something then in a plant a seed I had
where I'm like oh dude you're that
person already does that
I don't want for that reason then also
but but also like at the store like I
get a lot of inspiration from like even
in podcasts like Chris D'Elia came on
and was like literally the funniest hour
I've ever ever signed on find the kid
what do I guess the year it was it was
literally he left I was like ah because
I was like so inspired
yeah he's the funniest person I know
yeah he's the funniest most talented
person I know it was so good yeah and I
get inspired from that or if I like you
do new bits now my watch yeah because I
like what because I think if you just go
to the store and
see the guys who like they're getting
ready to tape a special or you see their
special like that's the final product
that you've seen you know if you're an
NFL game you see that on Sunday you
don't see all the practice them dropping
balls and throw an interception
if you come during the week so I like
seeing you know that Chris is doing bad
but he's not you know it's not for you
on fire inspired you see him working out
yeah oh that's how I would say yes
because I take two sometimes yeah
oh he's doing the same thing you know
for how long yeah so I get inspiration
from that I'm never stopping your open
my career as a comic yeah and then
there's all sorts of inspirational
things like I remember a few months ago
at the at the Laugh Factory like the
room just wasn't good everyone's eating
shit yeah and we everyone's talking shit
about the crowd and it's like I don't
know who's gonna go on you know we're
gonna do and everyone's kind of down and
Bill burr walks in on an ounce and he
goes in who's next
you don't want to bump anyone I think I
was next he's like is it cool if I gone
like do your thing bill and he gets up
there murder Oh murder Oh murder oh man
I was like best
I love it when bill is killing so hard
that he'll actually start bombing on
purpose
just to get back to having to fight his
way out of a hole
anything to watch I think it gives
everybody a reality check yeah oh no no
we're not all the same
yes Neal Allison yes we're all at the
Laugh Factory that's bill Berman yeah
show some respect
yeah like it's just like you see that
like holy fuck but he's somebody that
would never coast like he never wants to
plateau so sometimes he'll just say
something that's fucking insane just to
lose the audience like I remember one
time I think was at the Comedy Store he
said something he was killing so hard
and he said something like I did the
Holocaust really happen or something
horrific so that the audience who wants
to react and then he wants to earn them
back yeah I saw him do that that set he
had laughing he said something and a
whole room went oh yeah he goes why is
that offensive he does that and the
ladies like what he's like why do you
have an issue and then she starts going
and he's just ripping apart but enough
such a smart funny way or like that's
how he stays so strong is that because a
lot of times comedians if you're if
people are just laughing because they
know it's you you're not getting an
honest gauge on the material correct
remember one time Chris Rock was in the
Oh our and he goes and of course is
killed he has new stuff he's killing and
he's just wet it's not that funny
there's no way that joke deserved that
like please stop laughing
that's why Steve Martin stopped doing
stand-up he said he was you know he went
when he's doing you know I'm a wild
crazy guy like sellout huge arenas he
said he was already thinking about
stopping cuz it was just the attention
he was getting was so insane you know
how to deal with it and he's going to a
show and they have certain props in a
show and the prop messed up anyone
started laughing
he's a it's not no no and they have to
take time to get down but the crowds
dying and he's like oh fuck it's over
it's over man you think it's over I
think I can do anything impression music
I'm out you know you know I remember
when you took me like Garry Shandling my
brother was with us know we went to it
was Kevin Kevin Murphy say yes and I
think with script you and Garry
Shandling came and spoke this was
shortly before he passed away and I tell
you what's crazy about that I think
about that too is I got on this Garry
Shandling kick I like read all his books
watch his documented traps how brilliant
it was his journal entries break my door
Oh have you been reading them I just
watched it in the Apatow documentary
yeah that if you but I'll give you the
book I had finished with but they have
like his real journals in there huh I'm
on a plane I know I'm on a plane to the
end and his last journal entry imma try
not to cry and his last journal entry is
to his brother who passed away I'm on
Spirit Airlines so life is already bad
you're about to pass I was gonna try
anyway but this kid I was place very
cool guys no but I'm on then and it's
his last journal entry to his brother
his note to his brother
oh I remember crying on this plane it's
like I mean I get my place and I cool to
cry man if you motherfuckers read this
well it's not cool to cry I like when
guys cry it's sexy I don't care my
literally I cry all the time I could
Kobe Bryant yeah
I'm thought I cried fried two days Wow I
met cry if I came here yeah no it's
Crichton always I was crying in the
hallway telling about a story yeah of a
reporter's story about Kobe's yeah I'm a
super sense person I think I mean more
I've always been super sensitive I mean
more sense because I have kids now did
you always know that about yourself that
you're sensitive
oh is Yaya mmm-hmm always always what
has any joke hurt your feelings on any
of your podcast have you ever just been
they go that was that hurt me um
sometimes Theo say some stuff from a
site dark I love that line of road
you're right over it yeah I don't I'm
just like no but I'm just think I love
that I'm fascinated by when something
goes too far and why yeah I think it's
like yeah and you know feels so smart
and brilliant and it's just like I you
know I don't I couldn't tell you but
he's done every show but the thing is
this uh it you know I think it was just
I was good you know it might Bend when
Kobe passed away and I remember waking
up that morning like I don't I had to do
three shows I've stand up that night
like I don't want to be funny today I
don't feel like doing this
yeah and then with feeling it it takes
the most work out of anything I do
because I can't just go in there and
coast it's like I can be so on or you
know I'm playing what I want to gets
LeBron J
yeah so it's I I gotta be so honest
going do you hear how these clinking
fallen Charlotte's phone going off all
the fun I thought it was you know I'm a
professional I've never had much Jesus
what is the animal that mine is that
it's just my inner monologue cuter ha
it's my computer silences off sandwiches
off let me ask you a question for people
that don't totally understand the Kobe
thing I was trying to think yesterday of
who would be a quantum Asst in the NFL
would it be Tom Brady
like just this level of legend yeah Tom
passing away correct Tom Brady Brady
with his kid on the plane right mm-hmm
it's so heavy I'm gonna ask you some
questions because I love asking guys for
relationship advice for you not for me
uncle maybe well why not
at some point I'm gonna have to take
some Balak um
all right quiet sit we're at The Comedy
Store in
some dude was sitting on you like what
are you doing no one will talk to me of
like Rogan and you are uneven side of me
no guy will ever flirt with me no but I
think that a lot of women get advice
from their girlfriends and some
girlfriends give good advice a lot don't
because the word about hurting feelings
I'm big on asking guys about advice
about guys and I think that guys if you
want to ask advice about your girl or
your wife ask women yes your guy friends
for advice about women and don't ask
your girl friends for advice about men
but also don't ask your girl friend for
advice when she's been relationship for
10 years she's not in the game or didn't
fuck it or not in one at all yes yeah so
how long until it's appropriate to put
the person you're dating on social media
and what does it mean when a guy doesn't
put you on a social media are we talking
some normal person talking celebrity Oh
see that is like in your world that's a
tricky one I would say not all wrong I
think most people listening are not
probably famous okay I thought you just
had all like Hollywood listeners to put
on I I don't think it's that big of a
deal
I don't think it's that big a deal can
always archive that shit yes whatever
yeah it's not that but don't don't make
a big deal does that mean your
boyfriend/girlfriend yes okay
it means it's at least the essence phone
keeps riving me insane there has to be
like a hidden behind you don't you have
like four phone I don't know what it is
maybe it's my IUD activating my
biological clock
shipstation shipstation when you're
selling online getting your orders out
can be real pain how you gonna keep
track of what gets what well shipping
carriers should you use are you getting
the best rates well that's why you need
ship station comments the fastest
easiest most affordable way to manage
and ship your orders
I swear are just a few clicks you'll be
managing and your orders and putting out
labels and getting your products out as
fast and keeping your customers real hat
sorry ship station makes it real for a
keynesian that's what I know yeah
because you save money on shipping cost
number you if you're on Amazon Etsy your
own website brings all the orders to one
simple interface ship station versus all
the major carriers UPS FedEx UPS again
USPS Amazon Fulfillment number one ship
stations number one choice for online
sailors nothing we don't mess with
number two hey I know right now good for
you listeners can try station free to
people with speech impediments trying to
say ship station free for 60 days when
you use the offer code Whitney there's
no risk you can start your own free
trial without even entering your credit
card info please a miracle
ship station calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Whitney ship station dot-com
enter the code quit net ship station
comm make ship happen you know
Benjen that did you have life insurance
yes you know you don't I I did but I was
at Sephora and they rolled over right oh
no for sure you don't know then surprise
everyone which is a shame because I'm
gonna kill you the year 2020 shows up a
lot in science fiction sci-fi as we say
on pods a lot of people predicted by now
we'd be teleporting to work living on
Mars none of that happened
truth is we always get the future wrong
which is why we need to get life
insurance right now right that's why
policy genius is here to help makes
finding the right life insurance a
breeze it's a breeze and it's very lost
where we where it's a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers to find the best price you
could save fifteen hundred dollars or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policy once you
apply policy genius will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape
thank God so let's make your
science-fiction dreams come true for
2020 if your science-fiction dreams for
2020 still haven't become science fact
don't get discouraged just get life
insurance it takes just a few minutes to
find your best price and apply at policy
genius.com policy genius will always get
the future wrong better get life
insurance right
[Music]
not that big of a deal not that big
people are make it too big enough social
media it's whatever I think for most
it's a good style it's a good sign
okay so it's not everything right people
to put too much value on social media I
think for a lot I think that's an old
thing to say I think that a right for
someone who's 20 it's their whole world
all right let me say this put them in
your story don't put them on your wall
[Music]
Wow even your grid the walls the castle
walls oh they call IG walls your
Facebook wall no the IG wall that's your
main the tragic go ahead I don't call I
refuse call it the great red great and
then I want Mad Max the great
nope not happen Trump not called the
wall okay so if you're with a guy this
is people I said people send in a bunch
of questioned people submit questions
are people I just did it for you because
I want to do some oh well relationship
if I something you're really good at
advice okay
I think you're well thank you very clear
honest feedback oh well okay so if
you're if I'm dating a guy and he
doesn't put me on his Instagram after
three months what does that mean it's
probably something else is going on it's
not he's probably dating a few hmm and
if it doesn't mean doesn't care about
you by seeing a few people what is what
is that what do you mean so if a guy's
dating a few girls what does that mean I
mean he's trying to figure out which one
he likes the best
is that a I sometimes think it's a good
thing if you're dating me and you're
dating two other girls good you have
something to compare me to you'll like
me more I agree people are so like
territorial I call that's mine but it's
like if you guys are dating and he's
doing his thing you're doing your thing
it's good to feel it out you know I'm
saying like it's not the end of the
world
yeah if he's seen someone else but
awesome again to your point if you're
confident in yourself it's like yeah
compare me those others but there is a
point where that's got to stop correct
there's a point yes it three months up
to here it's a guy no and it's just too
much
no he's a he's an asshole let's just
move on he's an asshole hmm that's a
tricky one but yeah and also depends on
how old you are and how old he is
correct right yeah big time do you have
lots of platonic girlfriends no why not
most people don't I know um I don't know
I
a I don't meet a lot of girls who are
like yeah I don't mean a ton of girls
who like I'm gonna sit down and get to
know or have a conversation like I'll
meet fans or I'll meet someone if I'm
doing like a TV show or something like
that but I don't I don't get a lot of
time to do it's very hard to make female
or male platonic relationships in your
30s when you're in something it's also
hard like yeah
correct correct okay it's also hard if
it if it's like an attractive girl yeah
you know it's like it's so hard yeah
it's and I just love people I like keep
so it's like yet stuff I can't put up
that wall yeah I suck at putting up that
wall yeah that's right it's a tricky one
and I but I think platonic relationships
are so important but it's so hard for us
to have them like all my male comic
friends like before the relationships
are kind of in now when they'd start
dating someone new I wouldn't hear from
him for like eight months and then they
break up and they'd be like what's up
with tang yeah I think it's tough I
think it's tough I also think it's tough
you have to be comfortable cuz you're
obviously a very pretty successful
female so it's like if you do email what
one oh a mail a lot one sinks it's
because it's apple tonic
female friend if you bring some you know
if you're dating someone new you bring
around Whitney Cummings that person has
to have their shit like they have to
have all their boxes checked another way
that girl you know it's gonna be
intimidating you have problems I guess
you know exactly what do I guess what's
your favorite mistake you've ever made
Renan any good mistakes questions are
fantastic any good mistakes
sometimes mistakes are the best thing we
do I don't feel I feel like you make so
many mistakes I mean like a good example
is if you hurt yourself fighting making
a mistake and that's part of what got
you out of it to be doing stand-up you
know like just anything that was like at
the time felt like devastating and then
at the end was like oh thank god that
happened like how can you have there's
been so many yeah I've had so many from
when I was playing football
tuhhh yeah I think all the Harkey
relationship all mistake but you learn
something about yourself I think all the
heartache I've had from sports like it's
so heavy and it's like like in football
like just my dreams are shattered and
it's like finding light in that and like
it made me who I am today
and then the UFC just being like my
heart being broken that college football
my heart being broken like you just put
these chips on my shoulder I get to the
UFC and I felt like they were against me
so I found all these chips on my
shoulder so at the time they seem like
mistakes but now I'm like y'all thank
God they served their purpose like like
looking back it's like oh you were in
UFC the perfect amount of time to be
able to talk about it yeah intelligently
and have the experience and be able to
be a got all these other things right
would I crawl through some shit like
Andy Dufresne man like it
I should man some nights just be like oh
my god like when my football dreams
shattered I swear I was like so
embarrassed but wasn't it good that
they're shattered so that you now leave
the rest of your life now be able to
have a frontal lobe yeah and all that
for sure ya know but the time you don't
feel that way you know yeah yeah I need
some tough times it's just it's just for
me I'm obsessed with having hindsight
right now and just being able to go you
know what this feels like it's a bad
thing but I know that I'm gonna look
back in ten years ago thank God that
didn't work out agree right agree
hundred percent ya know it's like thank
God I'm doing this now that relationship
that I thought was like the end of the
world if it didn't work out like thank
God that didn't work out yeah but
there's also some things where it's like
like when you and I were hanging out
like I wasn't in the position for anyone
who I was dating like back in the day
like I was in a position I like like be
serious or date anybody so I feel like
rich is perfect for me because I
I love it unavailable person that I can
just project it but yeah yeah cuz I feel
like you know relationships especially
as you get old you're in your 30s it's
like just your you change what you
think's attractive or what you need from
so ya know yeah and I think that as you
get older and you kind of like figure
out how to get your own emotional needs
met on your own which is the healthy way
to do to not get internal needs met
externally then you have to figure out
what you need in a person you know
exciting when you're in your 20s are
trying to get all your emotional needs
met from one person yeah and you don't
know I don't know what you want in the
site you know especially I was in the
UFC it's just like yeah no fucking you
don't know ya have no idea and I think
the last thing you needed back then was
pressure and I think relationships
probably felt a quantum is with pressure
do you think yeah but I just was in a
spot to like I thank God we stayed
friends cuz you had your shit together
name like I'm crazy no but you had your
shit together from I mean I did block
you but yeah you did I said it's
t-mobile but I think you had your shit
together in like you're so like like
smart and like just like knowledgeable
and like life like much more experienced
than me which is what I needed but at
the time I didn't know it's like so I'm
trying to give you medicine like I don't
want that me keep taking this it's like
hey dum-dum
take the fucking medicine but I think it
also it's so it's actually like our
relationship is so valuable to me
because I also learned a lot about
myself in that you know I was chasing
unavailable people and I didn't realize
that that's what I was doing and I think
it's it's part of serious growth that I
needed because I thought I need to like
constantly audition for approval or find
people that I wasn't good enough for and
like I was just in like a weird rut with
that see that's not fair on for me to do
to you especially the time cuz but you
weren't doing anything you just were but
yet but I was like like you could have
been you know jaylen or 22 checked all
the boxes and would have worked out that
make sense yes no that had nothing to do
with and I know it's not personal
yes but I just went okay that my
intimacy issue or whatever it was my
fear of intimacy went oh this is the
perfect person because he's always
unavailable he's always training things
completely out of my control that aren't
personal I'm gonna go chase this person
just to make myself feel inadequate or
get some adrenaline hit or just justify
actually being alone
and sort of hoodwinking myself into
thinking I'm actually dating somebody
are you good at being alone now
at your age I'm really good at me at my
age okay well we're not yeah oh my bad
is this news to everybody in the room
I know it's young here I it's so funny
because I think I spent so much time
working on being able to be alone and I
might have gone too far with it because
I love me alone well I'm really good at
it I like my inner monologue now I don't
get scared that's such a superpower
it's a superpower but I also think you
need it in you know as a stand-up like
you know I mean I used to do 80 cities a
year I used to just be in hotel rooms
alone all the time and I'm I was like
facetiming with people in charge and I
was like you know I worked really hard
to be able to do it and you'd have to
for me I much prefer being alone than
being around the wrong person or with
the wrong people that makes me feel way
more lonely agree you know I haven't
mastered that at all I suck at being
alone really
Oh terrible Tim but the people you don't
surround yourself with trash people nope
you don't prefer that to being alone no
not at all but you also can't be alone
you have a family like when I'm on the
road or yeah just certain times or if
they're gone like I don't do well being
alone hmm what do you sense a superpower
be allowed to control that I also am NOT
believe it or not a lot of people might
not I'm not an extroverted person I talk
for a living but I get depleted by
socializing so I need a lot of time to
just get reset yeah I need so much time
and time to get energy see that's why I
like living where at giving your address
I like living where we're at because I
like that time I Drive in the studio I
Drive to Hollywood
that alone times the only time I'd like
think and not serve other people
yeah that's literally the only time yeah
I have where I'm not helping somebody or
do an entertainment I have to fucking
that drive and that's why I love doing
it and I think I've become a better
comedian the more I'm able to be alone
because I can just process shit and
think about shit and you know I think um
and I can be an audience member and have
a front row seat to my own inner
monologue which is usually what I'll
write jokes about yeah like why did I
think this about this so you just have
to be able to find some quiet and not
just distract ourselves the problem is
the phone is not does not count as a
long time me just sitting there on my
phone checking out liking so that's not
your that then then you're in a you know
then you're in a fucking video game yeah
that's correct
you're in virtual reality that doesn't
count and you're an adrenalin outrage
cycle you know but I'm working on now I
have to go back to being more social
because I think that I'm now isolating a
little bit too much a little too much
yeah do you think I don't know you seem
pretty have your shit together see my
right what's the best first date idea
damn
besides Chipotle stories I like I like
create ass I like I like live music I
think it's a good one can like movies
are terrible first date ideas why you
can't talk in a movie stay at home but
you go to hard movies so that you can
touch each other now come on I like like
any live music so Sharon Ellie there's
so much live means that's a good one I'm
not like don't go to like Drake yeah it
to me would have to be a band that I
like love it can't be like a new to me
if I don't know them that's the fun if
it's terrible then you make fun of it
you know right and then also if it's bad
you realize what kind of person she is
you know if she's shitting on the band
and not having a good time she's a
debbie downer like how for this chick
socks man she's got fun in it you know
good drinks the guys in relationships be
following bikini models on social media
let's be serious
why fault why why we following guys I
don't what are we doing I mean what are
you I'm unfollow them I think it depends
on the guy depends on the guy if he some
guys have a great discipline where they
literally like you know it's like if you
not to compare women to cars or it's
like you know if you follow the rock
whatever I don't know fuck you think see
but for guys it's like gonna come in a
relationship you know and that's like
for them like hell Jesus Christ keep
flipping I don't problem with it
what are you problem in bikini shopping
why do you need to fall bikini models
well you know it's like for what I mean
why watch gen France in a movie you
think he cares about her talent I think
guys like Jennifer Aniston yeah cuz
she's good-looking Whitney you think we
love Jayla's she has a box
who does Jenny Jenny from the block is
so attractive yeah has some hits if she
looked like saya delft seven years ago
it's not as big as hits we know this
this is it am I give me two is this on
it's all female 25 female I just don't I
do think it's very frustrating when
you're dating somebody and they're
following a bunch of like lingerie
models it's just like I don't depends on
the person you know you watch porn we
know you guys know there's no delusion
about whether you know it depends on the
person yeah like if you're a weird thing
to be like flipping through at work but
yeah that's strange but it's like a
jealousy dude what's that dude but it's
like a jealousy thing right yes
I just if you know he's loyal and it's
just for him it's like oh you know I
don't know I think but now she has
access if you're dating a celebrity and
he's falling you gotta figure out that
you're gonna have to yeah you know yeah
you can DM or whatever let me look at
your phone as the relationship over no
there's trust issues mm-hmm can you work
through that trust issue
I I know
I mean and I would never if like this my
thing if if I have to look through your
phone we price you me relationship
laughter hey can I get your phone yeah
what the fuck root no it's over
if the person is password and you don't
know that password no I don't care
you're gonna get caught that's you yeah
somehow it's gonna come out yeah yeah
I'm just asking so that and then if it
feels like an obligation is it over if
it starts to feel again I need contacts
is it the Saudis been made for like 10
years that's a good question okay you're
big too literal about these already very
very literal Valentine's Day gift what
do you know I have no idea that skips
trying to get through fucking Columbus
this week the best gift you could
receive as a man it's really hard to
shop for guys and I was like to ask guys
it's it's the toughest because I say so
saying because I have money if I want
something I buy it right so it's like
what I want you're not gonna buy me yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can I have to loan
you money to buy me the thing I want
yeah it's like tweed no don't buy that
yeah you know Rolex something that I
want no that's crazy yeah cuz if I want
you know I don't know what's something
that you would value materialistic like
it's some material yeah I mean there's
like a lot of why I'm a watch guy like
watch third person or watch like what's
a good present for like someone is that
you are poor that's a cheaper call ICT I
only remember this rich life all I
remember being rich sharing a couch with
your brothers like five years ago Jesus
and it's from Ikea I showed up late with
avocados house used to be on the 23rd
floor you're like 1906 F penthouse you
limited shit also reasonably oh so bad
so five years ago what would have been a
nightmare go back like I mean like a
right I don't know who I don't nine
years ago what would have been a gift
that you would have wanted on Val I
don't know I hate receiving gifts
really yeah it's awkward yeah I'm not
gonna do you feel like you have to
perform and I don't know it's just like
if again if I want I'm gonna work for it
and make it happen like what I want
you're not gonna get me you like it's
not I get like you got say all what do
you want right now you know I don't know
five years or let's put yourself let's
go back in time to five years ago what I
want yeah a juicer that's five years
yeah I probably on to juice get that
don't get your man a juice he's so
disappointed
why juicing ain't the thing anymore this
is what we found out just like cancer I
think I don't know my frame cells yeah
well what a blender that's a good gift
yeah one of those bullets would you like
the spokesperson for nine of them yeah
your company peloton is that $6,000 bike
I'll put a huffy can lease it though oh
really
okay did you make monthly payment a
peloton okay get your man a peloton I
mean I don't know this is a just became
a real bujji podcast no sorry I don't
know a nice dinner I appreciate it just
a nice dinner okay
yeah it's good like a gift card gift
card bag dance cuz that's your gift no I
think it's a good gift really it's lazy
gift
I think it's lazy it's the laziest gift
or it's thoughtful to go hey I've
thought a lot about this and I know I'm
gonna get this wrong and I don't want
and you don't know me very well
that's probably love because I would you
work very well I would you give me a $50
gift card to fucking tell when your
people now I have to go what I'm gonna
do with this see I said 200 to Best Buy
yeah that's what I said
Turner best nice pretty tasty you'll get
to pick out what you want you go to
Dick's Sporting Goods and you get
whatever you did this morning
200 of us while working at Best Buy for
two hundo I'm taking the TV you're gonna
get a DVD player one blu-ray player
giftgiving stuff man I know that's why
we're talking about it but you're really
struggling with that it's super
struggling how by the way do have any
notes for me no it's great you're like
who I you're like who I asked for advice
about this for podcasts yeah oh well um
no it's great you kept saying telling me
to be more personal yep
don't give us the TV Whitney no one
likes that Whitney Mimi
he knows that the system is on time at
what I'm saying why you even ready paid
for the podcast studio no I know but no
one knows that Winnie no one can relate
to that Whitney I'm in a different what
do you talk about it's like you asking
what to what gifts to give people
Valentine's Day I don't know you know if
they like people they you know they they
want to get to know Whitney that's why
she started podcasts you know I'm saying
like I can't like I don't but yeah I
hate when people start podcasting it's
just like this you don't get to know e
they don't pull back that wall like you
like her what are you doing dude yeah
like when they make it into like a TV
show and over produce podcast CI what
are you doing I feel like I under two
side just because Joey Diaz perfect just
have a conversation it's okay if it's
boring no one thinks it's you only think
it's more in because you're a comedian
people just want to hear you talk yeah
but people are here you talk and people
want to know like what Whitney's dealing
with you know I just don't have famous
people on there to talk about their
famous lives Kate Upton your guests are
talking about shitting and your tongue
I doubt by the way couple things one
time we were hanging out and we were in
a grocery store and people thought you
were heron Hernandez oh yes that's why I
grew my hair out when he was exactly my
era and everyone's looking at you I was
like it was what he was in the thick of
it too and I was fighting side my
headshot
Oh famous like oh is it like people no
no they all think I'm Aaron Hernandez
and I was really close to Tim Tebow at
the time too so it's like Hughes his
quarterback in college and I remember I
was at a grouse starting this guy is
like guys I mean he's like nah nah man
I'm gonna this muhfucka right now he's
in Marina del Rey Wow I'm telling about
the I get a pick dog in the picture I'm
like oh hell no so I grew this shit out
do this shit out
isn't there stuff that is you shouldn't
share about your personal life on these
podcasts like what I don't know I'm
asking you to give me advice I don't
think so I think more people can relate
to the struggles than anything mm-hmm
like if you go back to us fine kidding
me I cry on there when I lose fights
while us fights talk about why I got
fired from Fox yeah I've just always
been at the time I was like girl here we
go cuz yeah I met Fox was like Kate do
not go on your podcast tomorrow and tell
him all this stuff do not do that I go I
can't do that man I have to do that I'm
telling it's a bad idea
all right cool man so I did I was like
what when I want is a fence I went on
that next day oh wow blurted all that
out and then I get fired but I just feel
like people want like they want that
strumpet no it's too here you know
that's what they like instagrams for
your success and all like that's not
that's real man we're all struggling
like yeah the fucker man yeah not
everyone's all good I just feel like you
you know I think for me for the longest
time like I share so much about myself I
feel like and on what though
you don't think I share a lot about
myself on what on what platform on what
platform I did write a book about my
about a lot of personal shit okay cuz I
was too scared to talk about it I think
okay and I went let me just put this in
book form because I feel like I can't
say this on stage that's fair I shared
in my special
all about my boobs okay what else do I
need here on here yeah talked about what
on here what I talked about on here I
feel like I talking about pretty
personal shit on here I'm so I'm sure
you do I'm saying but that's why you
should do have a pot so you're saying
that I don't share enough about myself
on you I'm not saying that I'm saying do
you send me a text and you said that
well it's the first episode I would I
think what makes certain people great
podcasters is there's no you can remove
that fourth wall and it's not like
you're this famous rich person out of
your house doing a podcast more people
can relate to that than anything stuff -
right - and stand Bob see there's
certain bits people can relate to stuff
to relate on you know 2 broke girls or
you know you went to Penn and your
speeches they're like yeah alright yeah
Whitney's a fucking superhero man but
it's like you're also a regular person
and that's what the podcast is for I
feel like I'm a wreck on here on here ya
know but I also feel like I'm just also
might just be you
you know like once a rack that's what
you think that's you I also think that
I'm I'm just getting the hang of it
like I feel like I just I don't know how
many we've done but I feel like I'm just
getting the hang of it cuz when I
started I felt very rushed like I had to
get a lot of interesting content in yeah
you feel like it has to be like yeah yes
like really tight and punchy and I feel
like only in the last like two weeks
have I been able to just like chill out
and go like whatever happens happens and
if it's funny it's funny if it's not
it's not let's experience the same thing
with like letting the room sit like it's
okay that there's silence sometimes in
bits
yeah and it's okay to just like be
comfortable in the silence cuz you know
you're gonna hit a fuckin you know and
having it feel like an organic
conversation that doesn't have an agenda
has been really hard for me because I
think it has to be funny all the time
cuz that's old-school Hollywood yes it's
same thing like I do that food-truck
diary show on Showtime and then I guy
we're gonna give you these bullet points
on no no I don't need any of that just
get me a fucking food truck let me have
the guys on I want and just fill me and
him have a conversation yeah and then I
married some people come on the oh man
what do you want to talk about you what
are you into man mm-hm fishing let's
talk about fishing for an hour now what
do you I'm not here to another
I'm not here I don't care whatever you
wanna talk about me your kids let's do
it for an hour I'm not here to be that
entertaining it's on You Man and for the
reason people gravitate towards that cuz
the overproduced all that stuff if to
help man it's out so true I do want to
ask you this what are red flags in
friends and in people like if you were
dating right now
what are red flags giving content you're
good at this you're very we've talked
about this before
you're very good about this you're very
good about like how much social media is
too much like Schulz said I like a
private Instagram he likes a private
Instagram mhm but he has his public one
to know he liked it in a bit his girl
yeah his girl he went private Instagram
I like that I love that mm-hmm I love I
have an Instagram red flag someone who's
like trying to be an influencer but also
has like a job job who's like also
trying to be like Instagram famous is a
red flag only chicken heads then they're
a wall only being selfies as a red flag
you're really good at this we used to
talk about this we should talk about
this but those are red flags but also
when I was 25 those were red flags but
he schultz what but for listeners who
are like 30 like right the fuck are you
talking about
I mean selfies and what like a
deal-breaker maybe you've just been out
of the game for too long you're rusty I
feel like you've been oh I'm not rusty
I'm trying to think I would help people
red flags because like looking through I
mean look at the guy guys are it's a lot
of pictures of themselves you know it's
a lot of like to me they're bad person I
thought it'd be did you're a bad person
but like everyday like selfies it's a
lot for me personally I like to I want
to see a sunset every now and then I
want to see a fucking mountain range I
want food something anything anything if
you think you're the shit it's just not
that appealing to me no I mean let
sexism maybe that's totally sexist
picturing a guy pick up his phone and do
this all there's nothing Lisa track just
on a detective but it's your girl do it
to them like wow oh I'm sorry it's a
human nature baby girl
are you filter like that's just not sexy
to me I'm sorry maybe maybe I'm but it's
not sexy for a guy to see in a girl
either it's just like so like like oh
look at me something repellent about it
but we all do it and like I'm sure that
if a guy saw me do it they'd be like uh
like I have this like excuse for I'm
like this is my job I have to do this
I'll say that I think that it's also
watching it just feels like trying too
hard and it's just repellent to me I
also don't like when people try too hard
on their socials to not like when people
do like black-and-white photos with like
the white border around it so you go to
their wall and it's all like yeah take
it easy now you're just trying you're
not Ansel fucking Adams either so but
here but here's this whole conversation
from Schultz to this it's like you guys
are so focused on social media mhm
again I don't give a fuck from a girl's
finances or social media I'm not basing
any of that for red flag hmm like that
those those things you know especially
social media like that it's the Wild
West yeah we're trying to get attention
yeah but you know you don't know those
people
yeah the red flag Biff you sat down a
she's on her phone all the time you know
on the phone all the time usually a red
flag they have a ton of guy friends Oh
interesting she said that's me it's a
it's a little different because the
business you're in around comics so in
general the demo especially in comedy
it's real male heavy mm-hmm
for the reason the girls hate each other
so
and you have student loans I did you did
yeah I don't think I have I think
they're all paid off
you think you got a phone call you need
earnest if you have student loans
refinancing them with earnest could save
you money or lower your monthly payment
and it only takes two minutes to check
your rate online if you're still paying
the same rate you were paying when you
graduated odds are you could reduce your
monthly payment and save big big bank
even if you have refinanced before with
today's low rate environment most people
can save by refinancing again because
those loans will get you yeah they will
and no not only that they will call for
them Oh everyday your heels they just
keep they find you they always know
where you are earnest is the easiest way
to refinance your student loans saving
you time and money only takes two
minutes to complete a few questions
online you can even combine private and
federal loans that sounds complicated
but they're gonna do it for you they
have incredible customer service so
start saving on your student loans tada
our listeners are getting a hundred
percent cash bonus oh when you refinance
student loans at earnest calm / Whitney
hundred dollars cash bonus when you
refinance student loans at earnest calm
/ Whitney go to earnest calm / Whitney -
dah terms and conditions apply alrighty
my type of company whether you got a new
puppy or an old friend and in bark breed
plus health test is the key to unlocking
your dog's unique breed mix and
genetically informed health needs so you
can help your puppy live its healthiest
happiest life love this company from
breed traits to genetic risk factors for
health conditions embark provides
resources to help you and your vet best
tailor care for your dog specific needs
this works on a child I don't know baby
you can find out what your dog's breed
is the DNA test you'll have an answer
next time someone stops you to say what
kind of dog is that and we did it we did
it with Mona I know it's so exciting -
it was so easy I just swab the inside of
her mouth which I do pretty much all day
every day with my finger so it was easy
to do and I actually thought she was
Ridgeback Staffie but it turns out she's
a hundred percent Safi yes she is which
is very healthy I
and she had um I'm glad because I now
don't have to waste a bunch of money
sorry at the vet asking about what she's
predisposed to cuz they told me I don't
have to check a bunch of things very
helpful that's the kind of true science
I'm talking about that's that true
science T is what that is right now
embark has an inclusive offer you can't
get anywhere else go to embark vet comm
now use promo code Cummings that's my
last name to save 15% off of your dog
DNA test kit visit embark vet dot-com
use promo code Cummings to say if you're
gonna love it
that's so weird to me because it's like
female comics it's like for the longest
time yes there was one on each line up
and there was a scarcity complex but now
it's just not like that anymore like
when female comics are competitive I'm
just like what are you doing that's very
strange I guess in order to become a
comic you already have to be kind of
competitive so maybe it's like a chicken
and egg thing maybe you're already like
that it'll be off to be nice
cheerleading of up no no you don't and
also like I don't know I get why female
comics that are old or older could be
because they were so fucking roasted and
trolled in haze like I was so fucking
hazed yeah and if I hadn't have like
gotten therapy and done work on myself I
think I would be a really bitter
competitive nasty person yeah but but
you're not but I know that everyone that
hazed me was in a lot of pain like those
guys were just in a tremendous amount of
pain so the field you and you're gonna
have a lot of male friends just that's
that's that's because they're just not
competitive but but if the girls not in
the entertainment has a ton of male
friends hmm
why cuz you think all the guys want to
have sex with her and she doesn't know
it or she does know and she's on sex
with it oh it's a huge red flag Oh
compute read play huh huge the biggest
really I think it's a huge one no wonder
do all guys think that that's like an
own red flag it's just for the girls
attractive I think it's a red flag in
general friendships and relationships if
a girl doesn't have a lot of girlfriends
like if a girl that doesn't have a lot
of girlfriends tries to be friends with
me I'm like weird yeah it's always weird
you don't have girlfriends or a dog or a
cat if you don't have anything I have I
need you pre-approved by someone else
yeah that's weird
it's also weird if again if you're gonna
base off social media go to
profile she's on a yacht by herself who
do you think's doing it she's paying for
that yacht one way I'm telling you that
those Tahiti trips ain't free some old
dudes getting some work it's Catalina
Island and you said it was Tahiti I see
[Laughter]
I'm never letting you go what's the
longest podcast you've done on Rogan how
long what's the longest three hours in
Chains I probably a fight campaign we
did like four hours it's the last one we
were three hours deep and I was like I'm
out of here I go put my son to bed
Friday my set
he's like no you'll have to go I didn't
really that was a fucking optional yeah
and he just keeps doing did our and I
have to pee so bad and I can't even
focus it's such a win for me when we're
sitting there he goes I go to the
bathroom like go ahead I'm gonna ask you
this I remember around the time I met
you I was dating some guy and like we
were like arguing about something and I
was like look like you date me if you
want like a challenge or something or
like some guys just don't want to
challenge and he just looked at me
anyway why would any guy ever want to
challenge the guy you were dating said
that some guy was hanging out with yeah
okay and I was like oh
a lot of women what's the question the
question is why do women who told women
that guys would ever want to challenge
in a relationship I don't think they
want it too easy
you know I love it you're saying a
little pride bud is you know every guy
knows like oh my god this girl's so
dramatic I hate drama
you love it you love drama you love
cleaning up a mess you love chasing a
mess you love you love crazy you love
fighting but you're not gonna appreciate
if it comes too easy that's your guys
like to hunt
thank you Jesus don't you think a my
rock but I don't like the hunt I'm not a
hunter you don't like something that
comes too easy that's not my point is
that if you get that gave me that car
outside I'm not gonna appreciate it I am
I gonna wash it myself I'll probably hit
it on the curb
I worked my fucking tail off with
everything it took a while to get that
dream car so it's like I appreciate the
shit out of it
I think it's no guy has the balls to say
that because guys like no string like
crazy I don't like I don't like to have
to chase people I don't like girls that
cause drama
I don't like crazy I like interesting
yeah like interesting and well read to
unicorns but I think that a lot of guys
try to pretend that they don't like
drama and then they'll go women are
fucking crazy and I'm just like you love
it love it no they like you but again I
again too easy is not good too easy it's
not good like you're playing your cards
very close to the vest over here really
mm-hmm
interesting emotional jailbreaker is in
a sentence a guy is working with someone
and they like text like have an
emotional affair it usually happens at
work as my guess what happens at work if
you're confiding too much in someone if
someone knows your secrets more than the
person you're with or that kind of have
a problem with it emotional cheating I
don't have a problem with it because
obviously the guy or the girl doesn't
feel comfortable enough to do it with
whoever he's dating or married to so
it's like he's getting it out you know
and I think it has helped save
resentment later and maybe it's what he
or she needs at the time to get through
whatever she's dealing with and that
other person's check in the box they're
not a bad person man because because the
person in their cubicle next to him is a
great person a good listener and for the
reason she can relate to on that subject
but you're a girl at home can't oh no oh
no doesn't make him bad person doesn't
emotional cheating always lead to
physical cheating on some level maybe
mm-hmm maybe because I also think that
we have to actively not emotionally
connect we have to go like you know what
I really want to share this thing that
just happened to me but I need to wait
til I get home and share with the person
I'm with so I don't start just fucking
you know emotion sharing in a sloppy way
with other people is it that fucked up
though I think oh really I think you
have yes I think that emotional cheating
usually leads to some kind of physical
cheating degree or what happens is you
start emotionally connecting with
someone who's not your person and then
you're unavailable to someone who's and
then you're unavailable to the person
you're with so it's like if you're at
work connecting with someone connecting
with someone you think that you're so
close and then you go home to your guy
and you're like well he just doesn't
understand me understand you you just
haven't been telling him um or he
doesn't understand you and that other
person might be the one person should be
with ya and it's all good or you don't
have to get everything from one person
correct it's me tough to have someone
fill your cup one person fill your cup
it's tough we talked about this
yesterday I'm Frank you would dove
Davidoff in Callen okay stop really
figure relationships out yeah those the
three of us are degenerates but the
problem is that you know he's going
through therapy and you know obviously
is yeah oh yeah his brothers a therapist
and they were but they're talking about
monogamy and how you know this is just
natural for guys and you know the the
caveman and I'm like alright so what do
you do what do we do with that
information
yeah also you know I I just like that
information doesn't help anybody yeah
make you feel better about cheating or
doesn't you know a lot of what do you do
with that info what do you do with that
info okay it's on our DNA DB monogamous
but you won't end up like heaven you
know I'm saying it's just life
our life expectancy it used to be 30 so
it was for that life expectancy it was
natural but now their life expectancy is
80 it's just changed so now it's just be
monogamous a couple times in your
lifetime I think that's just sort of
though and they're saying that's not in
our DNA newest way to look at it ya know
a lot of things are in our DNA you know
beyond the Sun we fuckin burn there's a
lot of shit that well you have to do
really did dub you weren't around for
this
I had an epic meltdown at The Comedy
Store really once and of it wasn't his
fault dub Davidoff comedian great guy
was not his fault I mean I loved I mean
I just loved him we used to be really
close friends and he at red flag and he
came in from some night at Vegas and
this is what like all the guys were
really like this was like before
rogon was back before thea was there the
shit Joe it was a shit show
and it was like classic sort of like
glory days of The Comedy Store like
girls everywhere like it was just it was
we're scummy
yeah we're just scummy er sounds so fun
but it was dumb that's my way to button
up and I think I was going through a
breakup or something or I've been
cheated on I don't know what happened
but I was in wrong place and dove-like
had a girl there or something and there
was some other girl and I couldn't tell
which girl he was dating or I don't know
what's happening and I snapped like some
very old childhood wound triggers
scabbed was ripped off yeah I was
triggered my eyes flutter back in my
head and I just started yelling at every
comedian in the hallway and I just oh
wow you guys need to class it up
security to class it up Mike Young when
you need a class it up and you're dead
says I had like a helicopter arm does a
cute class every class with the fuck up
it was a know what you left there was
old everybody's like oh she snapped know
was like she fan snapping but finally
snapped because I kept having to meet
everyone's girlfriends and wives and
then I'm friends with them and in there
they're asking me what's going on that's
for this they do they go hey meet
Whitney and then I'm the one that has to
co-sign of the navigate feel the best
yes and then I'm friends with all three
of your girlfriends and they don't know
that they other one exists and I have to
pretend and I just got so sick of it and
I just like had an epic snare long ago
was that
okay years ago I would say baby 10 yeah
this is like quite a while hasn't been
in a while yeah no this was like before
they were married and it you know was
just like back when everyone was just
sort of just getting famous and
successful and this is you know pretty
mean to you you imagine anybody doing
like sit we're there tonight you imagine
someone doing that tonight you mean
cheating or being me no cheating its day
yeah I'm saying blowing up on other
comics in the hallway no wait no like
it's just not me a second I'm playin
cameras everywhere name it but it was
not it was like I think I had been hazed
for so long and I had like it finally
snapped fit my tongue for so long and I
was like the kids sister of the Comedy
Store I haven't looked back pack and I
just fucking snapped good for you yeah
was dove like what it was actually kind
of wild to watch everybody just go like
pale white like but I think also they
were like it's mad time she snapped and
then for her I was going out of the
disease change yeah I think I fixed him
there were doves demerits outside now
yeah everyone really bulletin you know I
actually look back and I'm like maybe I
did scare them straight you did gave him
the pep talk they needed I do think that
there are some people the economy store
like know that I love them and believe
in them who have said to me like
comments were like I just there are
times where I'm about to make a bad
decision I'm like I wouldn't want we
need to know about that and I think it
might stem from that night I bet I can
see how people screaming all these guys
and like Sebastian walked up and I was
like you need a class and then he went
up and I was like you're fine you're
cool you just keep doing what you're
doing keep it up buddy
after fucking everyone what else I know
you have to go soon I'm good what else
you got I don't know y'all you guys
usually do this we go pretty long three
hours we go pretty long I really give a
shit but now that you're telling me I
need to reveal stuff about myself no
don't listen anybody that's like a bunch
of secrets and reading my journal
because I do hold back a little bit and
I do need help with this well you just
start well yeah it is talking and being
entertaining is your skill set you're
saying really revealing things about
yourself and your skills but also how
many have you done 30 40 13 13 yeah you
know I'm saying I always just think that
I'm just warming up I like to prepare
and I like to be interesting and I don't
like to be sloppy and sometimes I just
think my life is boring mmm I think
you'd be surprised you know but also you
see you don't want to be sloppy and like
entertained but like you talking's
entertaining you know what saying like
there any comics that youth are
surprised how nice they are that you
were didn't think they'd be nice in the
beginning
and also how this lip injections going I
know I don't think that lip injections I
woke up like this
no I get it all the time and everyone
thinks I do my eyebrows
what do them like cut them I don't know
it was like a sweet eyebrows like
alright thanks man oh you might like
like trim them no do you pluck in the
middle no oh yeah I did nothing
literally never notice I've never looked
yeah I don't know I don't know ha yeah
but no woke up like this uh what was the
code I got a really good hairline uh
Walt kind of you do it's gonna slowly I
don't come - yeah it's like a really
good anti propecia I just gotta you know
comics have been super nice to me uh
chip L was really nice to me but you
just want to talk about fighting which
bum me out
you really don't like people talking
about that with you um it's just I don't
want them to just you know obviously
it's like if they know me from fighting
they want to bring it up I got but I
stopped going to Blue Bottle cuz I
basically do a podcast we don't pick up
my fucking coffee
hey dude the fight like on Monday though
you know give it a listen man so I don't
have to do it here please never wink
even in an impression about winking we
as we can out to enjoy a good I week but
also bad it because this I also
shoulders it's a tween it's so show it's
so Hollywood I remember when I first met
you we'd go places and people would like
either try to flake fight you or they'd
be like yeah dude I've used to fight and
I get the ice to get that other thing
like that how do you still fight man
that one time like oh yes please tell me
that tell me are fighting a bar that'd
be fantastic don't work like it was just
such a bummer like I just never had
thought about I thought being a comedian
was a nightmare because people come out
and try to be funny and they just always
end up hurting your feelings but people
would come up to you and just by god
dude nah are you both though how your
ball
are you people trying to be jokes a try
do you wanna fight you're like like what
yeah like the think something's funny or
I had one guys that pills coffee goes
dude love the comedy fighting out so
much I'm like what does that even mean
yeah I don't you when I was fighting you
in a fan I don't but might say that I
didn't make feel good yeah people do
they give you career advice that's what
I get yeah I got a lot of career advice
I get people like you should more
voiceovers I'm like what is that you
don't know anything about what's crazy
thing you're saying I know people that
like nobody how come you weren't Wonder
Woman and like because they didn't want
me to be yeah my mom still that's why I
don't get why you're not Batman yeah you
know hard is no hard that it's let me
take Christian Bale's job that's what we
do but they'd stirred like I don't get
it explain it to me and then you like
cuz I'm not good enough and he's also
very skilled they know where to find me
yeah they know where to find me
yeah or my mom like dude the rock
Jumanji 3 I just don't see why you can't
do it again yeah not my thing
do you watch WWF nope grown man but
grown man Ricky nice do the real thing
you know what is the comedy equivalent
to WWF like improv know there's some
good improv like um like what is it is
it acting it's a telenovela acting I
don't know I don't know blue man group
like what is it I don't know that's a
great question I don't know do you guys
not prepared fighting the kid not once
0 not once or or or King the sting have
you ever talked about a guest that was
disappointing oh yeah yeah oh yeah we've
had we've really had to happen twice one
was op C Callen booked this guy he was
like a porno director and his heart Oh
porno director his porn star and Bryan's
like dude I'm telling on your that
you're watching your wall yeah hey sorry
or no my bad
you can put on your grid sorry anyway
so he brought him up this is years I
mean fucking five years ago but he came
on there and we were like trying to get
like the behind the scenes of porno and
it was so disturbing and just like a
bummer halfway through I was just like
and Callan knows if I go hey I'm gonna
go the bathroom especially when the guys
in the middle of a story he knows it's
over yeah so I was like I'm gonna go the
bathroom coughs what do you think I go
we can't hear this man you didn't air it
but I'm like we can't hear this there's
no way we can hear this it was like so
just how about five six years ago at
least no so degrading and just like dark
and you're just like what are we gonna
do with this yeah look I don't wanna
promote this we're gonna do with this
hmm
there's that and then we had one I won't
say his name we got a comic come on
there carrot top
nope and he was doing bit like you'd ask
him a serious question like like hey
what's some red flags and he had a bit
on red flag but he did the bit but was
it communicating with us and just
powered through like where'd you just go
what's the context he did like context I
can't answer the question just grabbing
a sense yeah you just power through it
and did his bits and there's no car and
I was like oh this telling me now yep
and halfway do I like the pilot I gotta
go the bathroom got it my god we can't
we can't do this we can't enter this
didn't air it nope
have you run into the person since yes
did you tell him why I don't think you
even realized that it didn't get aired
the reason no can't four or five years
ago now if it's not someone that we know
yeah we don't need gas yes me and Brian
so unless it's someone that we really
want on we don't do gas yeah Jim steam
doesn't do guest what's the biggest
fight you've ever gotten in with Brian
biggest fight Brian I ever got in
probably probably when we first started
piked
three years in just cuz you know but I
want to be you know he's doing well in
acting now but the time you know he's
kind of you know trying to figure it out
he's doing some movies here and he's
kind of doing stand-up kind of not but
he wasn't committed to the podcast and
his actor friends were making fun him
for doing podcast you know that most
people in this business for a very long
time as a podcast what is this like it's
not did not take it seriously
correct and Brian got a lot of ships
like a sink
yeah I got a lot of shit from his
buddies for doing a podcast and he would
show up late wasn't taking serious I'd
have to do it by myself a lot of times
or bring a guest host on and I said like
so much resentment against them I show
up I think yeah I remember just like
dude just commit me I'm telling you just
commit and then Brian take today's like
you thank God man thank God thank God
because we there's a time where I was it
comes if you don't start coming man I'm
gonna stop doing it like three years in
probably I was a guy I can't carry it
anymore man mm-hmm yeah but I think that
for a long time it was like a lot of
people saw it it's like Dancing with the
Stars it's like what you did if you
couldn't make it in television or
something no one took podcast seriously
and people still don't quite understand
and now I would say every day a very big
influential celebrity oh what's up but
this podcast thing should I be doing
this so funny it's so funny so and I get
it's the only thing anybody listens to
your watches really especially as a
comic though yeah so she's a comic but
that was a fight but I was like over
time there's a fight other than that
nothing really you know Brian he's so
easygoing yeah it was time there we just
wasn't taking the podcast serious and I
that I had to do everything I'm just so
curious because I think a lot of times
when you go in business with your
friends you have to be ready for the
friendship to be line has never been
that way because Brian you know he's not
motivated by money
I'm not moving motivated by money so
it's like there's never been an issue
Brian was like and I didn't care he's
like man we spiced it down with a
Lorient figure the contractor that we're
making some serious money when you
figure this out and remember went in
there and you know the lawyers like man
you know so we should do 50/50 and Ben's
like um Brendan's the reason why this is
here it's gonna be 60/40 I'm like you
don't have to do that man Brian's aqui
no no no you know he's always been great
we've never had any like really really
bad blowout fights never quit the
podcast until those early years when he
was like coming like an hour late or
just disrespecting me mm-hmm
never I remember that it was bad man
that has attached so much resentment
against them I was just like so upset
yeah so upset it's a lot because I also
think it was like you were trying to get
out of a thing you know and he was kind
of just not like yeah it's just it's
wild to think how I mean we used to roll
our eyes at podcasts
we were just like and now it's just yes
Hollywood Hollywood's kind of trying to
fit is just starting to figure it out
Hollywood's trying to figure out cuz
they realize how much money's that's
right that's the only reason Hollywood's
trying and that's what took me so long
to do a podcast because that's not the
that's not the reason I mean there's a
million reasons yeah
it's brought to you by cash app um and
and I also thought there are all these
big companies now that are doing
podcasts and they give you this big
advance but then they keep a lot of
these and those things are shit and
you're who you're the reason I did it
like this
yeah you're the reason I basically
started doing a podcast cuz I had asked
for your advice yippy because the when
once Hollywood and those businesses get
involved there's gonna go the same game
plan they've been doing that's these
huge networks that control everything
yeah so you have me on I say something
outlandish you say something outlandish
don't get cancelled you at all man they
have nothing to do with it people
understand when you make a television
show in the last two that I've made have
been it's not happened for like crazy
devastating like freak reasons but I
think people understand you write
something then you turn it in to like 15
people that have never written anything
never written anything on their own they
maybe went to law school they maybe were
like the son of the guy that worked
there before one has their own agenda
everyone wants to earn their salary they
or and justify their job because they
have to justify their existence by
creating problems that only they can
solve yes which is by like giving some
fake bullshit notes or something
so you give 14 people your script that's
working and then they give you a bunch
of notes and slowly it starts to corrode
away and because they need to feel
involved in order to fight for it and
get you more ad money it takes three
years truly three years by the time you
get notes it's three years by time if
that project gets green light and then
you have to go cast it and find actors
and you hire an actor that they keep it
and then who's gonna want what network
give me a network who's gonna watch it
and by the way there's no such thing its
network no one knows what anything's on
so people come up to me once a day but I
love two Broke Girls and I always ask
them what network wasn't on they're like
mmm yeah we watched the show we don't
watch networks watch shows right we just
find them did you watch air yes I love
it
what's his name Jerome is it Jerome
Jerry Jerry he's so great
favorite I'm trying to get Monica the
coach on the pod yes she's the Knicks
Amite nick saban of women i don't know
what that means who's next amen
Nick Saban my favor oh wow my screen
saver right now is Monica from cheer I
should have Jerry on there I know I know
I could shove Jerry on here but I mean I
think I should he's doing so much press
right now
he blew I did so positive for him when
he's cheated fat I mean when he stood up
I was like has no one gonna acknowledge
his cheat it's so outrageous he's so
positive yeah I love him so much and
when he the first time he didn't make
mat and then the second time he didn't
make mat but he's the real he's so
positive fact that he didn't make mat
maybe the time and you're heartbroken
for and they stays in too strong like
goddamn I hate that guy I've been
talking shit out of that gym I love him
so I love Jerry you know I even looked
in buying Navarro t-shirts I can't I
just bought a new vard sure I want the
shirt on stage yeah I want this shirt I
bet we can get shirts made can't we
Benton hates my love I'm sure you don't
like Jerry whatever you would like
I watched it but I mean I I grew up
around very normal people so normal
people don't impress me the way they do
Whitney oh you mean because he's nice
and Texas is what you like him no I like
Jerry guy who's great he'd stay with my
aunt's friend for a long time he has a
Benton has an interesting theory on
shear that what did you say it's like
dragging the dog dragged in the middle
of America
that's like Cheerios yeah it
yeah there's no straight guys on the
team is there I mean um boys when I
don't know them over the zoom there's
not they didn't highlight any of them I
don't think they have a friend who was a
male children and he's straight as you
know yeah so you know Chappelle lacy you
know to Chappelle atomic oh he's great
he checked out
Louisville yeah yeah who's like I'll do
this fantastic I got so many girls I'm
like yeah yeah I think you're the
exception I just love it because it is
so hard
what they're doing is incredible right I
think so I think were they the the guy
who made it he also made last chance you
did you watch that so that's basic air
but football and it's with all these you
know college d1 rejects who they're so
talented they should be in the NFL but
they fucked up not a small school in
Kansas but they're the JUCO football
like Navarro is of cheerleading it's in
the middle of nowhere but the the last
chance last jet you'll love it it's the
best the coach is this white guy who's
born in Compton so he relates the black
guys yeah so it's it's so entertaining
it's more entertaining than chair and
you in the same director who did both
but he goes oh after I did chair you
know I'd say cheerleading's that it's
the toughest boat sport in the world
yeah take it easy dude but take it easy
I mean hey take it easy would you let
your kids play football if they're
really talented yes if they're just
running your mill fucking how do they
get talented if they don't you know you
know how yo know how my coaches knew my
parents knew because when you're around
other six-year-olds and you hand me a
football and no one can touch me I'm the
fastest on the field like I don't might
have something here but if he's just a
guy I'm like read a book what are you
gonna throw the football around yes like
my fire my for my four-year-old super
athletic like you did like you put a
ball out and it's game on he's just like
athletically he's gifted but again if
it's if he says if he doesn't have a
real gift at it you're not playing
football man but you so I'll know I'm
telling you I know it sounds fucked up
and I'll know but I also you know my
biggest problem is why I have
insecurities now about my intelligence
is like when I was playing football
especially at CU you major in football
but we my my my major did not matter
like they gave me the easiest classes
and I would go into my advisor but I
don't need the class with the other guys
like I I don't have to show up for class
on making these these tests like I'm
telling you give me real classes man
yeah she's like this is the schedule
that works with the practice and so I
just remember to like I know this I know
this
yeah I'm really kid you're saying you
don't want your kid going to college and
not getting really I don't want to I
don't want a major in football if you're
gonna well it just depends it's tough
it's it's so tough do you think
footballs gonna stay around in our
lifetime yes they'll never go away
never it's too big it's America's sport
what happens if but I saw I think CT
you're like yeah no shit dude UF CT CT
is also um CT well yeah it made me funny
no I'm just kidding I think I think CT
is over it like yeah we have the studies
now and people have to pass wait to
realize what's happening and you know
I've seen Hernandez was terrible but
also those studies are being so
exaggerated and it's you know most guys
are okay the percentage of football
players playing all their lives and
played for 10-15 is most of our okay
thriving Tony Romo you know is one of
the best comte's in the world I mean
concussions he had Troy ting that's one
of the best in general those guys were
okay
there's the exception with Junior Seau
and in Hernandez but in general
footballs okay and Aaron Hernandez just
have more than the average person or
yeah he had the worst they've ever seen
in that age group I think was 24 and he
had the worst CT they've ever seen at a
certain position that's the most common
that happens in uh no I mean he played
tough you don't sleep with a play tied
in so he's getting hit a lot but the
worst thing I've ever seen but I do
think like everyone's focus so much on
CT and football and how bad is free but
bring so many people so much to joy and
a lot of people that's how they get out
of whatever situation they're in it it
does great things but those studies when
you look into a lot of those studies are
over exaggerated but isn't also
concussions are under recorded also like
it's only recorded if you actually go
out like a lot of guys get concussions
and they just we're sure the sorts the
small concussions but in general the the
general percentage of guys that play
football are just
hmm just fine never thought about that
and what absolutely gonna do yeah what
is he gonna do yeah and if you asked all
those football players especially let's
play in the Super Bowl on Sunday hey man
you're probably have CT when you're 70
yeah
okay fine I'll have something when I'm
sad what else am I gonna yeah yeah yeah
what else win do you think that college
players should get paid yes that's the
biggest crook the biggest scam in any
institution it's so fucked up it's so
fucked up it's form of slavery and then
they go oh well we're giving education
no you're not I was there man
yeah that I was it's an awful education
no it's not real you're passing the
classes they're selling jerseys and
they're making millions and millions of
dollars off that kid when Tim Tebow is
playing for Florida and then when asked
championship he had the number one
selling jersey in the world over Michael
Jordan over Kobe over Tom Brady the
number one selling Jews in the world how
much money received for it zero that's
it's so fucked up basketball - yes
why don't they pay them it's just a scam
eventually they well once comes around
to it but it's just a matter of time but
it's just so fucked up
because you look at a guy like - who's a
correct for Alabama he's supposed to be
the first pick in the draft and he got
hurt roll tide roll tide
what's up girl he's Nick Saban he's the
bass college coach there so but that kid
- ax was supposed to be the number one
pick in the draft he got his last game
you got hurt blew out his hip
so he's fucked so let's say can't play
anymore he want you want a national
champ sold all these jerseys you know
what happens to him
I don't know work out fucking Blue
Bottle asking me question you know it's
such a bummer Wow and who changes that
who has to do something I don't know the
institutions you know college is such a
heavy institution and - good luck man I
don't know and then they won't let kids
there turn into sports but but they
won't like kids like like in basketball
you have to go to college for a year you
can't go straight to the NBA
what do you think that is why because
they have to make money off that player
before he goes the NBA and Wow all the
guys in the room are nodding in NFL in
the NFL if you play college football
say you graduate high school it's a very
rare but let's say you graduate high
school and you're ready for the NFL you
me the first pick nope you uh played two
years of college football why do you
think that is so the institution can
make all that money and then you can go
it's so fun this is so fucked up how
come the cheerleaders don't make any
money this is cheerleaders no one's
paying money to watch cheerleaders yeah
that's when they're like oh it's you
know football you know like it should be
if you have women make this man make
this like yeah
no I'm not doing that but I don't want
to do that I doc you don't wanna do it
I'm not gonna do that with you but
here's what I will say I'm gonna play
devil's advocate because that's what
comedians do we say things we don't
always mean don't bring it so n be a
basketball okay they make like $15 an
hour they make a hundred dollars game
basically okay okay and they're not
allowed to date two players okay if
they're gonna make a hundred hours an
hour they should be able to date players
in my opinion yeah they can date the
players they don't want it not allowed
or the maybe that's NF but y'all know
you're not allowed to date any of them
but it always happens like they always
date men
yeah but what's the point of Chi what's
the point of doing it unless you're
gonna get a I agree you know I mean I
agree I thought you're gonna offend
paying the cheerleaders more I mean I
don't I don't you could probably pay the
mortgage I mean is that even minimum
wage I don't know how many hours of game
I don't know I don't know how many hours
they practice yeah I think they make
less than minimum wage and the benefit
is maybe I'm gonna meet this guy or
maybe you know and yeah because votes no
one's getting famous off of it yeah me
Paula Abdul was a Laker but that's right
but notes gets it I do think
cheerleaders should get paid more cuz
they asked them to do appearances for
free they need some sort of you I know
nothing about this but no you're right
they need some sort of yeah that's what
they need some sort of Union yes they've
no leverage though because they anyone
else would do in a heartbeat
yeah because the here's if and if you're
a NFL owner and those cheerleaders like
hey we want more you owe us this you
know we want more picket signs if I'm an
owner I'm like cool yes and go away
let's see what happens ticket sales
let's see if nothing oh no nothing
nothing but none offense but
not not a thing nothing but not a damn
thing no no it's cool yeah did you enjoy
but no he gives a flying fuck that was
my prom with that cheer show I'm
watching those kids going they're
putting all this especially the the one
with the fucking helicopter parents I'm
watching her do you want what do you
want for which one I need I taste my
face what do you want fried I want
Gabby's parents to back the fuck up yeah
and let her live a little also my dad
making calls and get me a bikini line no
you don't I do i do say that I think
that her dad is getting way too much
shit he does see what he seems super
creep I think so too but like shooting a
Sheree walk till the cows that ass good
Oh like everybody on the show seemed
really Hollow except for Jerry they were
all very sad to me how about the hold up
how about how about the emo chick well
get to her her name that does not end
well
lies no it's not what is her name Nemo
chick I was just checking I was just
texting with her Lexie you attacked with
her about Changi about her
Lexie we'll get to Lexie in a second but
Gabby let's slow down with Gabby I can't
remember what the argument was but I got
these parents yes I don't I think there
is a weird war on men where no man can
do anything right if the dad was absent
we would say he was an asshole if he was
taking her to practice we'd say he was a
pervert if he's helping her build her
business he's two hands on what version
of Gabby's dad would we not Crimmins
don't like the red flag of it for me the
first red flag was another had an
interview with it it hasn't - dude how
you his daughter but him and his wife
there's hockey and his wife's like oh
that's not he's will you just have the
story go ahead to the story I saw the
story already
you've never been pissed off in an
argument
I'm just saying that my question to your
wife get the fuck out of here
both no come on no here's
problem with here's the problem here's
the problem is when they go man you're
doing this schedule during this schedule
when you get done you know I know you
want to rest but you got to do this
against here like dude I don't want to
do you get to tell she's like I'm
fucking over this man like you're not to
go here do this through this I'm like
you got to let that girl be a fucking
girl man because when this ends it's not
pretty
she put on fucking a hundred pounds do
you mind a thousand pounds sister new
show on TLC and that's how it ends she's
new back flips and she wanna be a
champion or not she was made what I'm
playing devil's advocate maybe she was
she's like well I want to win I want
this I want this bikini line and then
she's sitting round on her phone being a
brat and not taking care of herself he's
like well do you want to do this thing
or not
I put a bunch of time into your career
I've raised you I put all my savings
into these fucking sequin uniforms now
hold on hold on wait here's the problem
those parents career is their dog he's
known as business I know how
documentaries work I know how TV shows
work I know that had they manipulate
people to look certain ways Lexi story
she already came out and said that the
the John's Lexi Lexi's the blonde emo
girl her raving that was before Daytona
Beach and they put at the end to make it
look like she on ceremoniously was
removed and then was just like vaping at
raves that was she not removed from the
theme she was but then she got back and
then did Daytona Daytona was before that
they could change what she did get
kicked off in dip you late was she on
the team she's on the team back at the
end yeah and went Delta so she's
goodness the rave was not at the end
switched it so they do a lot of it yeah
they do a lot of manipulators the
problem baby
maybe maybe but here's the thing
everybody in every documentary says the
same thing and Hernandez wife is like he
was not gay he was not a murderer the
guy I'm fucking making a murderer
listen Brandon Bass is actually very
smart the Michael Jackson guys are like
I'm not buying it yeah I just I just
think and I know I'm playing devil's
advocate a little bit because you know
I'm the first person to be like a dad's
not let handlings right I just I don't
know I I just think there's something to
be said for having expectations for your
kids and my dad
fucking Road Meese that's such a gross
thing to say but that's a sink no bro be
so hard about what it's so hard with
studies and I'm so grateful that he did
and I hate it at the time but my work
ethic is all from my dad for sure if my
dad talk about something different
though I agree with that
me too if my dad was in a documentary
about me everyone would think he was a
fucking asshole yes so grateful that my
dad had such high expectations and
worked me so hard and if my dad should
add some Whitney Cummings bikinis their
one pieces you dad managing your tour
and your merch not and making sure you
shopping Cleveland works and then when
you go pop I need a break on I mean now
is not the time
capitalize on mine fucking Jessica
Simpson's parents did it Miley Cyrus's
parents did it a Katherine Heigl's mom
did it hold on what go through those
three examples let's talk about all
three of them happy to afteron Heigl how
bad it has the house in Utah doing great
works whenever she wants
yes she set a crazy thing on ellen fein
not a lot of people like her but those
pills are getting paid anyone would
fucking take her career it's what she
said I don't shows so not her car after
the Judd Apatow stuff after the yep she
got us a show okay so she said you
wouldn't work you say USA they say most
watch net net mush most watch Network
bullsh on TV network that's not true
u.s. there's no way that's true let's
watch that work you have a show on there
so what's going on there all right see
now you're now this is fucking this is
shit i do know shit about USA it's the
most watched network let's watch what
show well as a blue-collar factor more
than ABC NBC American Idol
bachelor/bachelorette most-watched cable
network all you're changing the to Burn
Notice changing top Network I'm googling
this right now okay so Katherine Heigl
you love her household name movie star
Katherine you're so loose with them
movie star drive your loosey-goosey with
movie stars right now she fucking
stepped in some shit but her big she's
your mom did everything she needed to do
sure her mom
showed up okay her mom handled Chet and
Vader rich and the house in Utah house
Miley Cyrus's mental Gatien she's
self-destructed on her own she was a
child star that's different from like
eight Gaby's not yeah he's a child star
Gabby got famous at eight doing YouTube
YouTube videos at the pop wood filming
doing the splits confusing keeping your
kid accountable and not giving up he's a
lot of beams who is that guy such a such
a tape throw up what was I just thinking
up I don't know I just think that Oh
who's your third one I think parents
Jessica Simpson who is a great career
billion dollars billion dollars come on
the show anytime Jesse can't add has a
billion dollars I love justice she's
fantastic she was my favorite out of
like those girls was like Christina
Aguilera Britney Spears and Jessica
Simpson adjust Simpson calendar I think
we're too hard on stage parents I think
you're confusing
that's not hunting either you're
confused on discipline and stage pans
but also there's a if you're getting
followed by a camera crew for four
months you're gonna say something dumb
you're gonna do something dumb you're
gonna lose your temper but if that dad
acted that way towards you how would you
handle it my dad did act like that
towards me my dad used to fucking make
me stay up till 2:00 in the morning and
quiz me with vocab words when I'd
already taken the test let me tell you
turn down and look at me now it's a
tricky line man
I just think I and look here's the other
thing my mom is from Texas and I know
that is a mentality that is just a very
specific look we played
Winn we're not here to get second place
take it easy I'm just saying bricky
Bobby take it easy
that's just like a mentality that I
value that mentality and I've discipline
I do too but not but back but here's
what I don't like it's also I don't know
this guy and I know a lot of people
think that he's trash but oh no I don't
think he's a bad person I don't either I
don't know do you not I mean but I if
she goes it's my dream in life to be a
famous successful cheerleader that she
said that to her I did you hear that I
didn't hear that from her mouth I heard
her putting myself on YouTube at eight
years old yeah yeah how to edit and do
all the YouTube channel the dad did you
don't know that you don't know that kids
do kids are very Monica and he's not
Monica is the better example of I think
you saw a sliver of who he is and we
were of course I did we will never know
who he is
and I'm not like going on here's what I
just don't like that when a parents no
one was going after the mom by the way
people only go after the dad because we
want to go like oh he's Creed I went
after the mom there are guys who have
daughters who are in gymnastics that
aren't trying to fuck their own
daughters like why like why do we go
there I never thought that both the
parents were getting so many comments
really i sat there overbearing but in
order to be the best of what you do you
have to have overbearing parents and
coaches and excellence doesn't coaches
coaches yes lacks a day's achill sloppy
as parents I hear you and here's what
say if your kid is in that kind of a
competitive lifestyle its 24/7 this
father has given up his life to drive
her because he had nothing else to do he
needed to make money off his daughter at
eight years old on YouTube how much
money was he making offer I'd like to
know this
I don't know he looked like he had a
stack of fucking documents he was making
calls to people for some clinic a
hundred excuse me a hundred dollars a
ticket this guy's working harder than
anybody what blood sweat tears trying to
make his daughter's dreams come true it
brings a tear of my eye how much he
gives a shit
and she doesn't even care I'll tell you
what that the emo chick wishes she had a
dad like
that she's at lalala they're fucking
shows up and we're yelling at him you
know I'm not yelling at him I suppose
she'd backed up a little let her be a
kid but he's on a documentary and
they're like we're here to see how you
parent and he's a garden I got a really
look like I'm doing shit like yeah baby
he was probably trying to impress the
camera people maybe what else should you
watch thousand-pound sisters know I know
you love that so good what does that
mean I don't know I like the newest
episode that I felt it was over it was
over produced they forced the connector
attitudes though they're outlawed pounds
thousand-pound sisters one six hundred
ones four hundred their fights they're
so funny there's their YouTube stars
that's a loose term their YouTube stars
and they do like you know funny videos
and just they're really funny they're
outgoing they're obviously 400 pounds
one six hundred pounds but you just love
them yeah like Route four is that isn't
that unhealthy I mean are they okay
that's the point to show they're no
they're not okay once 600 once 400 I'll
make the show fun well why would you
want to watch that I mean it because you
Ruth know you root for him okay and the
ones gonna shit together
yeah if maybe if they had a dad who
fucking bottom line they have terrible
pain they'd be in shape and maybe that's
why they gained weight yeah that's
exactly I think you owe their parents
are on the show too
well the mom was there but it's a shit I
don't know how well they can't be
illegal for your child to be 600 pounds
well they're adults now they're not like
kid kids I'd say me too when they're
that big I don't know how do you even
move around that's like Gilbert great
remember it's exact what is one needs a
walker one came and walk the other ones
like getting fit a lot of one got
approved for surgery the other didn't a
lot of times that um is from trauma
yeah you get that big because you had
some oh that's cool the salt is a child
or something and you make yourself big
and keep weight on to protect yourself
from some kind of abuse yeah you don't
get that big without some kind it's
fascinating right yeah you root firm I
hope it works out what works out of they
trying in shape yeah one shapes all
relative to trying in some sort of shape
they're trying to get Gabby's dad yeah
hold it oh you turn you out okay yeah
the real hero of Cheers Morgan which one
did it all alone oh I love more due to
my favorite shout out to
such a nice person and yeah it's one to
hug she felt unseen and I was like you
you do worked so hard the underdog she
was the Rudy do I mean the real heroes
are the ones with concussions that just
got dragged off the last three episodes
like what happened to her I was so
nervous when they went home boy blew his
ankle out and they had to redo the whole
thing I was no I know I've seen all of
that I'm trying to remember at the very
end when they're in Daytona state oh boy
literally blows out loud to read you
have to redo it I was like oh dear God
please make this happen and the fact
that they were doing all coverage from
cell phones because they couldn't
actually get access to that to shoot it
I loved that
oh you mean wrongness I mean I just
think so much more kind of a stress oval
yeah I was so stressed I wonder I really
do wonder if that is true or if the
documentary filmmakers just did that
because they knew it would be more
cinematic intense no true the fact that
they couldn't get actual access you know
I didn't realize how big of a deal I
mean I usually I've spent so much time
in Texas I didn't realize how high the
stakes are oh man and I'm fascinated by
the fact that their two rivals are like
in the same town basically yeah I the
end when they show the emo girl just
crying staring out to the ocean see xox
it's all downhill from here no way I
talked about this with a friend of mine
on Tex last night she's actually a good
artist her art is very good edge my
piece
no okay I said you good I will and I
will and I will buy a Gabby bikini and I
bought my Navarro cheer hat I wanted to
borrow a shirt you should make them they
don't have a shirt from on Etsy can we
make Navarro cheer sure it's just red
Bobo you're just stealing merge because
is that legal
oh I don't think Navarro is gonna care I
think they're stoked for any of the
publicity
look at this cuz I got this hat this
Navarro cheer hat you don't like it you
don't like it
I'd like the real legit Navarro chair
huh oh it's time to get the website yeah
I could have made that killer merge to
hit the maliki oops
the cell phone so bad do not wear that
so bummed but Lexi is doing fine and
then what was the other there was one
other girl
I don't remember I'm taking a photo of
you and Frank you have any questions for
me I don't think so
you can have your dog we really could
talk forever why don't you have a dog I
don't know you know gachy
such a crystally a thing to say I don't
know you know well he has some five now
for now does he afford yeah he just
found one on the street I like little
dogs though I like this thing I don't
not like them I don't think you like
this big Panthers yeah cuz we have
coyote wearin coyote holy just big
Panther where you going after this what
do you mean what are you after the show
yeah I'm taking there's a jump castle
place it's a jump center it's fun it's a
lot of work for Papa though injuries no
nothing mm-hmm I remember being in like
Amsterdam trying to help you get like a
cortisone shot in your hand yeah I'll
have in your hand you had a hand injury
no my wrist that's right that's right
yep they did it it's better now no pain
I have zero issues none zero it bent
when I jump and try keep up my kid on
the trampoline you know trampolines not
a joke all those things are dangerous
that's big nyah and then there's and
there's some cheerleaders in there might
be from Navarro not sure but they're
doing flips and shit myself is popular
you do that
popping I'm like there ain't help I
can't do that dude Papa can do so do you
like this half-assed cartwheel then
realize his dad's not Superman breaks
his heart oh no what a disappointment I
know so I take classes to do flips
you're taking classes to do I'm saying
should I to try to impress your child oh
yeah no I think it's good to show your
kid that if you can't do something you
say you can't do it and you don't try
and hurt yourself you right I think
that's a better example yeah you're
right sure you know what I can't do that
and that's okay you're right you right
you right you ready girl this is fun
this is really fun they always want to
fight me about anything
you know I was nervous no I don't think
that was a was that a fight because we
basically agreed I just said he needs to
it might be the way they cut it and but
the stage parents aren't cool because I
kids end up hating the sport here's the
problem that will end on that we all in
on this point this guy's so if this
guy's so over this show if you show me
the vodka I'm the one that asks him to
tell me the time he's good so he has to
what fuckin Chris D'Elia ramble on about
silly Billy for two hours just silly
goose she has to watch Chris yours
Chris's pockets used to just order post
mates and sit there so funny he's the
funniest guy in the planet I mean at
least before some of the content is
happening how about I was gonna ask
Chris where he gets us here who cuts his
hair and I was he was goes oh geez I go
all I got talking about something that's
all I was gonna ask him because I would
my stylist right now is not working with
long hair and then a bunch of other male
comms cameras what are you gonna ask him
it cuts his hair I think he goes to
Supercuts no he would never cut his
fucking hair and there was something
wrong with it where it always looked wet
and I was like is it dirty or is this a
gel or like a pomade like when you have
long hair there's a lot that goes into
Floyd's are used to his room used to be
legitimately like a American Girl doll
yeah I don't like cut it was long long I
have no idea but wait no the thing about
the for me I just don't understand where
being a good father fineline parent and
a stage dad when it starts and when it
stopped that's a fine line Hey look I
was a competitive athlete yes I know if
you know this but when I played AAU
basketball the parents would fire the
coaches I mean the parents were there
all the time every day and half the
girls went to fucking Tennessee in UConn
and they got scholarships it's what it
takes I was like where's my I wish my
dad was in here fucking yelling at
people
I used to watch this girl the dad would
French braid her hair like the crazy
shit and make her just like shoot
fucking free-throws free throws free
throws and she got a scholarship to
UConn yeah I agree with you on that I
mean I did Karate for 10 years and I
used to hate going say howdy I did cry
fruit three weeks days a week time bro
yeah but I love it I mean nothing I just
wanted something to do I mean nothing
else to do we would drive four cities
away yeah do it
great parent I would be miserable but I
really have I did it because I taught me
not to like quit things great parenting
and you know a black belt mm-hmm I used
to coach competitions and then I want
Gabby to at some point
with her agency go you know what dad I'm
good
she is the one that should say it's her
father not the fucking Internet she
should just go you know what dad this is
too much whatever I can do that I can
take it from here she's gonna have to
it's better than the other way it's
better than being completely absent I
agree you know at least he fucking cares
I think I think a lot of fathers right
now are just like what do you want you
want me to be involved you want me to
not be involved if I have all time but
just don't look at her like a cash cow
you know I'm saying like let her rest
maybe she's fine she's always exhausting
associates talk about tired she is I
want to talk about her skin though was
just something what is it
it's just that skin it's because of all
the Tanner it's self tanner I don't know
I don't know maybe that some fishes I'd
like to ask you about that but a lot of
people don't know
poached egg Animorphs what's that
sponsor you know brought to you a tumor
definitely not but let me tell you
something self tanner the reason that I
don't do self tanner is because it
breaks you out
spray-tan not Persian so you don't do
self tanners all the time because I am
an albino but if you have a bi boy I
know I know but that was not in for a
very long time my alabaster skin is
finally in but it wasn't for a very long
time everybody's in one leg when you
knew me like when we first met I was
doing a lot of self tan yeah you were
yeah face it it would like rub off on
shit's like on my car everywhere but it
also really breaks you out I think
that's what's happening with her and
she's sweating all the time because
she's working out and she's makeup on oh
that's right she's sweating homework
that's what it is any questions about
your entire skin lot see real top thick
and tough it's just sit good under her
skin her fault I'm saying I'm saying
like the shoulders and her letting I'm
telling you man she's 19 it's probably
tanning all the time to wait real tan
here you what what is what is the
alternative theory that you're not
saying might have done a stack of anavar
with a steroid that a lot of girls not a
legal that I'm sure they test them I
don't know oh mama you think they're
testing at a Juke
for steroids Monica would not allow this
it's Monica having that it's a college
don't they have to test you know have
the money testing some of those steroids
we need to improve in bulk Morgan off a
little bit we did yeah we need to give
the emo chicks up all right until until
next time how did you ever like do in
your podcast with real things Brendan
Schaub org no none I wish Brendan Schaub
dot that edu no it's just for what
tickets where we going yeah tell me
where you're going I don't know when
this comes out neither do i what's
coming out where it like you're touring
touring let's say it's comes out i got a
theater run in okay I think in March
Chicago Toronto Minneapolis New Orleans
Atlanta I'll be early enough I mean some
of those that's all in March we're
tasting at the trailer end and then
April I go to women he's go see Brandon
his audience is all growz such a cock
fest just like a hawk fest
it's like Dungeons & Dragons convention
hmm yeah yeah there's no chicks little
bit the whole week the comic store it
just bro so came out a good selfie oh my
god damn have any girlfriend wild need
some girls I know some girls at your
show good to get some those are my shows
girls tonight's bachelorette parties
you're gonna go I look out I just need
crowns at my shows like the little
Tiaras in trouble everyone's a night
that's trouble their night and that
turns into fucking shit Joe all right I
love you Brendan Schaub calm no it's not
it's tea fat cake um I don't have a
Brennan job done what yeah what are they
tea fat cake Oh got it okay got it
branding but all your tour dates are on
your Instagram Twitter I leave Twitter
you can check out my Instagram on my
wall nothing codes old souls the oldest
oldest guy okay I always end these
really awkwardly really yeah how do you
not have like a sign off what should we
do I don't know she would come up with a
sign up yeah I have to pee so bad you
got a piece of ass
this is my buggy memories all mean to me
early on no he barked to you the
beginning cuz someone threw him out of a
car but then he'll be your best friend
yeah we're best friends though I'm about
to do a big tour also thank you for
don't ride elephants and don't go to
zoos zoos are bad is that a new thing
you got the new things really a lot of
them the grill is in pretty Appetit
they're on the drugs the girlís my dog
Abby
[Music]
you